on some days the memories come flooding
back memories of the era known as the
troubles in Belfast Alfie McCrory
experienced terror Northern Ireland
firsthand he was there when a bomb
exploded on the Schenkel Road his
neighbourhood and a Protestant area nine
people died it was one of the worst bomb
attacks by the Irish Republican Army or
IRA in Belfast people land all over the
people somber day and some were injured
some were on their own tears 25 years on
the memory is still in people's main The
Hurt distiller and the loss of people
who have lost loved ones is still there
the attack was a turning point for Alfie
McCrory a Protestant he has wanted peace
ever since that day the Catholic and
clave are doing is just a few blocks
from Schenkel Road the bomber Thomas
Begley came from here he was a member of
the IRA Begley was killed by his own
bomb and today he's venerated by radical
Irish Catholics like D Fennell for us re
volunteers who were martyred had the
ultimate sacrifice for his freedom well
in any war there's death Republicans
have traditionally saw that as long as
the occupation remains I'm clear Sam the
Irish people have their ather as a
static impatient that would include both
arms that's presently being the
Republican viewpoint brexit seems to be
bringing back the identity politics of
Northern Ireland's past and as such it's
a huge test for the peace process the
question is whether any change in the
status quo would trigger a violent
reaction on either side
at the memorial amber fast commemorating
IRA fighters killed during the conflict
it becomes clear 20 years after the Good
Friday peace agreement the Catholic
community fears a so-called heart border
on the island of Ireland it would be the
external border of the EU in Freddie
accreting who needs to be honored and
respected doctor took away at the heart
border
he takes out away from us and then
things come every generation for all the
years has been back the transsexual and
that can't happen again Alfie McQuarrie
and his Protestant friends also feel an
existential threat they want to remain a
part of the UK and are against Northern
Ireland being given special status as
the EU has proposed Teresa made me in a
statement that the UK will be leaving as
one so we took God as a reassure and
said we're just as important of the
Airman's as the église of Scots in the
Welsh
betrayals the big word not practice
braixen means accent we're worried about
betrayal alfie McCrory hopes the
atmosphere will remain relatively quiet
despite the impending brexit but for the
first time in two decades there is a
sense that peace and Northern Ireland is
decidedly fragile